in my last video I discussed the
pathology of the center the pathology of
identity by using guardians of the
galaxy as an example and I want to move
towards explaining the pathology of the
margin as well the chaos of the margin
but before we get there we need to
discuss the transition of one pathology
to the other and to do that what better
way is there than comparing the movie
Shrek to the Greek drama
baki by Euripides just seem like the
obvious comparison to make so the movie
Shrek is an upside-down fairytale and
because it is upside down it is one of
the most illuminating movies ever made
for someone who wants to understand the
periphery because the peripheral
elements are put in the spotlight so now
a trick for those who want to interpret
symbolism is if you want to understand a
movie it's best to pay attention to the
beginning for in the catalyst of a story
the movie usually announces itself
reveals its symbolic structure and this
is the case here the movie starts with
Shrek reading the basic fairy tale motif
of the princess held in a tower by a
dragon the story is told by a in a
beautifully illustrated manuscript a
book is almost always an image of
knowledge tradition order and in this
case it is also beauty so as he's
reading Shrek rips a page out of the
book to use as toilet paper if you want
to understand the subversive effect the
margin can have on the Centreville this
is an amazing example right there every
process every system every tradition in
human existence cannot be total it
cannot contain everything and in a very
important way it should not attempt to
contain everything that's the Tower of
Babel motif once more for every complex
human
process Herrick your system there is
always something left out a residue a
remainder something that does not fit
something that is not consumed in terms
of process or also margin or fringe in
terms of space a system can never be
perfect the fringe appears as chaotic
problematic multiple accidental like the
dregs at the bottom of wine the peel the
rind it's that extra time we need to add
in leap years for our calendar to make
sense and and waste human waste is the
most immediate version of this as is the
whole panoply of accidents produced by
the process which is human digestion and
that is precisely what we are treated to
in the first moments of this movie a
litany of potty humor and inverted
behavior which could bring glee to any
three-year-old washing with mud fishing
with flatulence implications of
cannibalism and it's funny because
that's what funny is laughter is an
involuntary reaction to something which
does not fit something upside-down
something unexpected laughter is seeing
the limits of a normal process and so
the margin has a dual function by
marking the limit of something it frames
it it shows its end and is therefore
akin to death but by being this limit
this end it is also an exposition of the
vulnerability and insufficiency so the
notion of wiping oneself with a page of
a traditional fairy tale book is right
on as you can get if you want to show
how the margin can overrun the center
and that is precisely what the movies
track is about in the movie there is
this Lord Farquaad with a
cest with order and perfection his
kingdom is excessively straight and
organized and because of that he
proceeds to empty the kingdom of
strangeness to imprison anything that
doesn't fit that is not normal
basically all the characters of fairy
tales now we have set up the two
extremes shrek wants to cover the fairy
tale with waste and the anal-retentive
Farquaad wants to contain the fairy tale
by imprisoning it completely when you
see shrek was living in a swamp
and not bothering anyone doing his
inverted thing on his own it is trying
to control or contain the marginal which
will push the ogre who was pretty
content to wallow in his mire it will
push the ogre to confront the lord the
ogre has literally lost his traditional
place in the chaotic buffer zone of
society if you thought Occam's razor did
not have side effects well think again
here the side effects come back with a
vengeance in the case of Farquaad the
desire to fully master fully control the
strange will backfire on him and we
realized that the reason why Farquaad
wants to do this is to hide his own
insufficiency Farquaad is impossibly
short which actually makes him on the
verge of being a fairy tale character
himself when foot when shrek finally
brings the princess to Farquaad Farquaad
gives him the deed to his marsh but you
see that's not how it works
there is no deed to the margin no rule
no measurement to the chaos on the edge
by this point it's too late the monster
will have to take it all take the whole
structure down he will have to take the
princess it's like in the matrix the
architect has tried to fully account for
the anomaly that is neo within the
program itself so you can't
that that's the point to try to do that
has sent the world into extremes with
both the totalizing self-replicating
Agent Smith ie ego from guardians of the
galaxy ie
Lord Farquaad facing the anomaly the
thing that does not fit one extreme has
to break now these extreme duality the
duality of the Tower of Babel as
reaching for absolute unity and control
until bringing about absolute
fragmentation is shown in the movie
quite perfectly at the very end when
Farquaad realizes that his princess has
a monstrous side his princess has a
shadow which he cannot handle she
displays the very strangeness that
Farquaad wanted to control there is
always always a serpent in the garden
and so he begins to scream I am king I
will have order I will have perfection
after which he is devoured by a dragon
the devouring by the dragon is then
echoed in the structure by the
transformation of the princess who are
surprised becomes not a beautiful
princess but rather becomes an ugly ogre
the periphery has won the married couple
of Shrek and Fiona leave in a garlic
clove and then we're given an image of
an impossible mixture when a dragon will
marry a donkey I mean love is love right
and the final scene is the tikar the now
handicapped gingerbread man oh sorry
gingerbread person appears and then they
say wait is it they say or is it they
says not sure anyway it says in the
guise of Tiny Tim god bless us everyone
and this is the everyone which is
important this everyone takes on a
significance we could have never guessed
in theatres in the original frame given
by Dickens now it's important to
understand that all of this started
because of the excess of control and
excess of identity Farquaad is actually
obsessed with himself like ego and
guardians of the galaxy and there are
very ancient stories which describe this
problem and the most obvious is the
story of the Greek tragedy the Bakke by
Euripides in this story t-ten theus of
Thebes does not want to recognize the
existence of the god Dionysus who is his
cousin now notice the relationship of
identity Dionysus is pentas cousin
having been born from the god Zeus and
the human simile now right away we
should ask question why is Dionysus a
God and not a demigod like Achilles or
Theseus but that is part of the
undecided nature of this god he is the
god of wine the god of euphoric states
the god of the fluid state he's the God
of wild nature and presents himself as
coming from the outside that is though
he is a Greek god he appears as a
foreign god of the east and in the drama
he presents himself as an effeminate
foreigner all of these images are the
image of how the margin leads us away
from ourselves away from identity of
course there's something you for ik
about this ecstatic chaos and so the
subversive possibilities of this fluid
God are intensely real Pentheus just
like Farquaad is guilty of a sin of
pride a sin of the right hand we could
call it and because Pentheus refuses to
acknowledge even the existence of
Dionysus to let exists something he
cannot understand or control Dionysus
makes the women of the city
mad makes them rush out into the
mountain into the wilderness and act out
back an alien frenzy for this King
Pentheus actually tries to imprison
Dionysus but his bonds can never hold
that which is by nature the limit of
what can be contained and then comes the
move then the relationship of identity
plays itself out for Pentheus has the
snake in his own heart of course just
like Farquaad in being a borderline
fairytale character desires the ogre
princess without realizing it in fact
would have been too Pentheus advantage
to know that in the outset but now it's
too late
Pentheus is pride in blinding him and
Dionysus asks Pentheus if he would like
to see the Bakke the women out there in
the mountain I'd like that says Pentheus
yes for that I'd pay in gold and pay a
lot why is that Dionysus asked why do
you desire it so much I'd be sorry to
see the women drunk comes
Pentheus dishonest reply and his own
pride has bound him to the swinging
pendulum soon
he is cross-dressing and he sees two
suns in the sky the world is breaking up
into multiplicity and before he knows it
as he himself is going mad he is being
ripped apart by the mad women in the
mountain just as Farquaad was eaten by
the dragon
the tyranny of the margin always
proceeds from a tyranny of the center
exactly a pendulum swinging one of my
favorite visions of this relationship
comes from st. Maximus the Confessor who
frames this problem on the individual
level by using the left and the right
hand symbolism saying quote the passions
of the flesh may be described as
belonging to the left hand self-conceit
as belonging to the right hand unquote
he speaks of the excess of virtue quote
demons that combat us by the lack of
virtue are those that teach us
prostitution and drunkenness greed and
jealousy the demons that combat us by
act by excess of virtue are those that
teach us presumption vain glory and
pride who are the vices of the right
secretly placed in us the vices of the
left now noted how well maximus captures
this movement we see in Shrek are in the
Bakke the first sin is always a sin of
the right hand the first sin is always a
sin of pride it is the sin of Satan it
is the sin of Adam the sin of Cain the
sin of Babel it is also the sin of Peter
who declares that he of all people would
never deny Christ and then proceeds to
deny him through time if the margin has
one if the margin has devoured the
center the pendulum will swing once
again and this swing the margin does not
expect for just as the center cannot
fully contain the margin within its
order the proponents of the margin end
up re-establishing the center by
devouring it for that margin will
inevitably end up taking the language of
identity of pride and
exclusion those things that were the
very weapons of the center but such a
contradiction can no more hold than its
opposite the inversion flips back on
itself
and the seed begins to grow you see
there is a power in the margin but to
retain that power it must remain the
margin there is an authority of the
center but to retain that authority it
must leave room for the fringe to unfold
without absolute control that is the
tacit agreement made by any traditional
society but that agreement has been
forgotten in the absolute categories of
modernism rationality facing the
absolute chaos of post-modernism and so
the pendulum is left to swing and where
it will stop nobody knows